bueno
[Música]
el 7 de febrero de 1992 hace ya 30 años
en pleno final de la guerra fría la
unificación de alemania y el fin de la
unión soviética los estados europeos
consolidaron las bases que le daría una
comunidad política el tratado de
maastricht no sólo sentó los
lineamientos para crear la unión
económica y monetaria sino que también
ya como lo dijimos marcó un hito en el
proceso una integración entre los países
europeos integración también política su
principal acuerdo fue dar la carta de
una naturaleza a la unión europea en la
actualidad de muchos retos muchos retos
pendientes en este bloque y el futuro es
incierto con las tensiones en ucrania
también temas como la migración y el
proxy que están pendientes y entre otros
para ello entonces quiero saludar a
nuestro primer invitado del día ls jose
manuel azcona catedrático de historia
contemporánea la universidad rey juan
carlos de madrid gracias al profesor por
estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 le pregunto que
dejó entonces éste está grave más
estrecho cuál es su importancia teniendo
en cuenta que antes de ese tratado ya
existían otro tipo de acuerdos
comerciales
bueno primero muchísimas gracias por su
invitación
efectivamente lo decía muy bien usted
antes del año 92 aunque el tratado entró
en vigor el 1 de noviembre de 93 existía
una unión económica que surgió en
1958 fundada por alemania bélgica
francia italia luxemburgo y los países
bajos que era la comunidad económica
europea no ahora bien respondiendo a su
pregunta porque es importante más trick
y su entrada en vigor en 1993 porque
crea como usted muy bien ha dicho una
unidad política y una unidad política de
corte federal pero una unidad política
pletórica de instituciones comunes como
son el consejo como son el tribunal
especial bajo el centro de lópez o el
tribunal de cuentas y desde luego
la comisión europea no es importantísimo
es importante decimos bueno tan
importante esto lo tenemos muy claro en
esta parte del mundo que el entorno al
entre 60 y el 80 por ciento de las
decisiones que toman
nuestros jefes de gobierno primero el
ministro se centra en realidad tienen
que estar sujetas a los designios de la
unión europea no con lo cual el margen
digamos de maniobrabilidad que tiene
cada estado nacional atrás de sus
gobiernos pues está muy vinculado a esta
unión política que nace en
1992-93 no en política además en todos
los campos económico social cultural y
también importantísimo en la política
exterior y de seguridad común ahora
profesor también históricamente en la
unión europea ha buscado nuevos miembros
esperan más países en el futuro y de ser
así cuáles podrían ser los que se
adhieran a la unión europea
pues bien en este estricto momento de
esta entrevista y cinco países que son
candidatos albania macedonia montenegro
y serbia todos al este de europa y es
muy interesante porque claro también la
federación rusa actual de putting y dvds
porque como saber qué bien se suelen
compartir el gobierno pues estaban
interesados en ellos porque son zonas
absolutamente de su influencia la guerra
fría no todos los candidatos y en el
resto pues estamos en distintas fases no
los dos iniciales los que continuamos
después entre ellos españa en el 86 y
luego los que se metieron en la unión
los que entran en finalmente en 2004 que
la mayor ampliación por tanto los ríos
se expande hacia el este más allá del
eterno debate de turquía no aunque
parece ser que el atún y actual
ha decidido ya de una manera casi
definitiva más definitiva no formar
parte de esta de esta unión en la que
tuvo mucho interés en la década de los
90 no por tanto expansión hacia el este
molestia mucho sentido de la federación
rusa
como estamos viendo también con con
ucrania que aunque no es candidato
oficial insisto dentro del conflicto y
diría yo descarte el cuasi definitivo de
turquía
definitivo entonces es turquía para
entrar a este bloque de la unión europea
veremos a lo mejor si en muchos años
después se vuelve esta intención del
estado turco de hacer parte de la unión
europea pero profesor ahorita hablemos
de la organización histórica entre el
reino unido y el bloque comunitario
porque pese a que permaneció muchos años
dentro de él antes del prestige se dijo
que su relación y su adhesión al bloque
nunca fue completa porque esto
no es verdad nunca fue completa es más
en muchos sentidos había muchísimo
malestar en el en el resto de los de los
ojos pero muchísimo la llamamos es esto
es incuestionable no por qué pues porque
como el dios de la sociedad británica
gastó que la iglesia está dividida
siempre en un furibundo el nacionalismo
lo que les hace llevar a creer yo no lo
entiendo así como analista no como
historiador no entiendo que es así que
todavía es una gran potencia en el mundo
y nadie lo veis pero bueno y el gobierna
sino una parte de su sociedad y por otro
lado les venían a otras partidas
sociales les venía muy bien no entrar en
en estar en la unión porque la unión
europea hay que recordar aquí que
después de eeuu con el aporte al pib
mundial del 22 por ciento está a la
altura de china es el segundo depende
los años sobre tercero estamos ahí en
ese aporte al pie del 16 porque no tanto
conviene estar en unión europea
este nacionalismo esta forma particular
de ver el mundo de su sociedad generó
muchos problemas con la unión europea
muchos bloqueos y muchas fuerzas en
contra y esto generó también en el resto
de la solución pues un hartazgo no
aunque evidentemente no salí a la
superficie pero yo soy consciente de
ello y entonces al final venció la
oposición y amor más nacionalista más
etnocéntrica de su postura que yo creo
por cierto que va a ser un error pero
creo que fuera de la unión europea hace
mucho frío en la unión europea es una
potencia en muchos sentidos entonces por
ejemplo en mayores y dentales dentro en
el mundo mayor libertad acción diversión
y donde hay una masa de capital muy
interesante para ayudar y desde luego
para el fomento del comercio y de la
industria y de las relaciones económicas
creo que es un profundo error y lo
veremos a medio plazo ahora profesor ya
me quedaba poco tiempo pero no quiero
dejar de preguntarle qué va a pasar
entonces con polonia y hungría que
tienen tensas relaciones dentro de la
mayoría de los países del bloque además
le digo hacia dónde va la unión europea
sigue fuerte en el número pueda perdurar
muchísimos años más
bueno muy interesante la pregunta en
verdad bueno empieza por el final yo no
tengo la menor duda de que va a durar
muchísimos años pero para los que
vivimos en ella me permiten articular mi
opinión particular pues estamos
encantados con las razones antedichas no
yo creo que va a durar muchos años más
allá de que pueda haber vaivenes porque
algún otro país en su libre derecho
soberano decida no está ahí en fernando
no lo veo no lo marque bien
como he dicho antes seis países muy
interesados en entrar pero lo de hungría
y por mí es muy muy interesante porque
son dos países
repudian abiertamente de forma clarísima
las influencias recibidas en la etapa
comunista y que han impulsado un modelo
pues más vinculado a la tradición
cristiana a la tradición digamos
culturalista europea y entonces está
generando muchos problemas porque a
veces contradicen normativas oeste en
las legislativas comunes de la unión
europea en temas tan delicados como la
inmigración por ejemplo se niegan a
traer en migración musulmán si en cambio
hay muchos bien los rusos su plaga nos
en su suelo de tipología digamos
cristiana en eso es más vertientes es un
estos distintas vertientes católica
protestante ortodoxa pero sin embargo no
quieren mezclar con la sociedad digamos
musulmana
y este grado genera muchos choques bueno
más allá evidentemente de que las
decisiones que muchas de esto más
judicialmente la unión europea chocan
con sus modelos procesos determinados de
hacia dónde va a ir con la unión europea
como castigo ha entrado con el castigo y
entonces lo que va a seguir así